- Over 2,000 years ago,
the city of Zhenyuan
was built on a natural moat.
Sandwiched between mountains,
intending to keep intruders out.
But today, tourists
flow through the streets
of the famous Venice of the Orient.
Built in 205 BC during the Qin Dynasty,
The Wuyang River divides
the city into two parts:
East and West.
Numerous small canals, rivers and bridges
dot the landscape of this ancient city.
The city also thrived from trade.
The Silk Road of the South
went through this city
because it was the only
access point by ship
from South China to the central plains.
Merchant ships were docked here
from Vietnam, Thailand and India,
eager to move through
the port to the capital.
Today, you will find
remnants of old and new
married perfectly in this ancient city.
As day turns to night,
the stunning views turn
into a neon wonderland.